all right welcome to
the 100 000 subscribers
celebration i'm starting just a little
bit early since i see a lot of people
already in the chat
uh having gotten ready for this um so
i'm gonna
talk a bit about some of the things that
i wanted to
you know kind of go through um but let's
have a little bit of a toast i'm i'm
actually
it's gonna be coffee for me because it's
a little bit early in the day for me to
be
drinking alcohol um it's noon here
so even though it's you know it's a
sunday and easter
and holiday and all that sort of stuff i
unfortunately have to get
some work that i'm behind on done today
including writing
you know portions of a paper that i'm
going to be presenting
before too long at the saint anselm
conference coming up
later on in april so when you
procrastinate
then you get extra work i might do a
video sometime about how
like past greg screws over present greg
screws over future greg so in any case
um
thanks to everybody who's here thanks
everybody who's part of that
100 000 subscribers it's only taken 10
years to get to this point
uh and we'll talk about why that's the
case in just a minute
but you know here's to all of you you
notice we've got new
coffee mugs that are less spillable than
the other ones that we have but
um yeah this is a great uh time you know
we passed up the
100 000 subscribers a while back but um
you know it was like towards the end of
the month last month and i was really
busy with stuff and so i didn't want to
try to pack it in
i thought i'd find a day that would work
out
and i i forgot that it was easter sunday
so there's probably
some people who are you know who would
be here who are you know busy with with
other things with family
or religious obligations or things like
that
so um what i thought i would talk about
is you know a little bit of the history
of the channel
and how i got into this and you know
some things that might be a little
surprising for
uh listeners and viewers
and then i wanted to talk about like
some of my ideas about what i want to do
for um you know things coming up a lot
of which are like
keep on trucking with the same stuff but
adding a few other things
in or going back to some of the things
that i did earlier
and i'm actually going to be running
some polls in the youtube channel
about some of those particular video
series that i got started
you know whether people want to see more
of that or not
um and then i thought i would just you
know take people's questions comments
you know all of that that sort of stuff
um
so i see some back and forth about you
know uh
an oxford cambridge annual boat race i
you know
i know people saw that i posted a video
about
people um practicing in the milwaukee
river i'm not into boating if
when i do get into something that has
rowing it's a row boat or it's a canoe
i don't do you know uh the team rowing
stuff or
or um even kayaking um you know i grew
up
in in you know around lakes and stuff
like that but
it's i'm much more pedestrian and old
fashioned than that
so you know and i i don't pay attention
to what anybody else does with
with that sort of stuff um
some people are saying good evening
imagining that that a good
number of the viewers are over in europe
um
and uh yeah people are saying the mug
looks like it keeps heat in yeah it's
quite quite good for that
a lot of congratulations thanks for
for all of that um all right so let me
talk about the
the channel itself and a little bit
about why it took 10 years to get to
this point
like most things in my career
and life it's not the product of an
awful lot of
concerted planning it's more like well
you do this thing
and then that opens up some
possibilities and people are like yeah
you should do this over here
and sometimes i listen to them and
sometimes i only you know implement what
they're saying
a couple years later and you know
my career has been that way a lot of
things in my life have been that way
and the youtube channel has has been
that way i started it out
basically back in the old days of
youtube when
individuals couldn't put out
too much uh content as far as length
went
youtube had these restrictions first i
think it was like 10 minutes
then it was 15 minutes then it was 20
minutes so as a private individual
you could only upload things like if
they're a longer
lecture that you had video recorded
you'd have to break it up into chunks
and so
when you see those old videos where
people are doing that
that's what was going on and so i did
that with some of my conference
presentations
the critical thinking lectures that i
think got me a lot of traction early on
they're actually not in my channel
they're in fayetteville state
university's channel
precisely because you couldn't upload
long you know
50 minute lectures so i i
never actually got those back they've
they've been driving traffic to fsu
which i left in 2011
after that semester ever since then
and the reason i started doing them in
the first place was
um well there were a few things so
when i was at fayetteville state
university they were really
struggling but they were investing a lot
in faculty development that's like
teaching faculty to do
new things and one of the things that
that got my attention
was the center for excellence in
teaching and learning which is like the
people who train you know the faculty
and how to do things better
they wanted to do this thing where they
would come in and video record us giving
a lecture
and they had a guy with a giant camera
you know
and then they would give it to us as a
dvd which then we would use for tenure
and promotion
it was really interesting because i had
somebody come into my classroom
and i was cool with it i realized
afterwards that i'd misspelled the word
enumerative on the board uh for that
lecture
and it was there you know the whole time
glaring error you know but i was i was
okay with being on camera and i noticed
that a lot of my peers
they did not take to that as you know
quite as well they get really nervous
and so i was like okay i guess i can i
can do this
and then at that at the time my fiance
andy
uh now my wife uh she suggested i should
start doing what we call lecture capture
which is where you just like you know
video record your your classroom and so
i i started doing that at first i was
like uh who's going to want to watch
this stuff you know
but she was like give it give it a try
you know and we went back and forth
she's always much more optimistic i'm
much more
pessimistic about um you know trying
new new technology or putting things out
there
and sure enough a lot of people really
like those critical thinking lectures
and then i started shooting other stuff
um the chalk and talk
lectures were quite early you know some
of my conference
presentations and it just kind of went
from there and then when i went to
marist college you know i moved up to
new york to be
with andy from north carolina where
fayetteville state was
and i started teaching as an adjunct at
marist and i said hey can i can i video
record my lectures and they're like yeah
no reason you shouldn't just get a
release from the students because
there's some privacy issues and so i did
that
and many of you have probably seen those
early
you know introduction philosophy and
ethics and eventually i taught you know
religion and american culture
as another class there um and then you
know
um pretty quickly i was i was uh
not just you know teaching face-to-face
but also teaching online and so then i
started shooting
lectures for the online classes as well
as recycling
these these lectures and that was like
what i was doing
in the early years right it was all kind
of whatever happened in the classroom
i mean sometimes you see like a student
will bump the the desk that the
the flip cam was on it shakes all you
know or they're coughing
and you know that's not really optimal
recording stuff
and then i started recording in
classrooms without any students and that
was kind of
an interesting thing to do you know i
i i realize a lot of people have trouble
doing that they need an audience
for me i i never really had that much
difficulty talking to an empty room not
just because i
you know uh want to hear my own voice or
something like that but i would always
just like imagine the people who
might be watching this and would get
something out of it
and so in any case i started recording
other things and
usually they were pretty long you know i
also recorded some you know
more personal stuff back then i talked
about like teaching in prison or
you know i'd answer a few student
questions about like love and
infatuation or i talked about
you know struggling with depression and
and in any case all of that sort of
stuff
um you know um we
it got more and more people watching it
and and they would ask me
for things like hey can you do lectures
on
hegel you know why don't you tell me
more about this
and you know that that um
audience or subscriber whatever you want
to call it and producer
interaction has been pretty important i
gather that a lot of people don't
read their youtube comments or respond
to them so i was kind of an outlier
in that as well because i figured why
would you have comments if you're not
going to read them
but i guess a lot of people don't or
they they farm that out to somebody else
and you know the channel just kept
growing and growing and growing it's
it's been growing at a steady rate
there's never been anything that was
like
a big you know now i finally have
traction
moment it's just been grinding away and
producing stuff and
you know i've made a lot of different
kinds of videos at a certain point i
came to realize
people have been saying you know videos
need to be shorter these hour long
videos are too
long and i i thought okay well i don't
want to do the
[ __ ] five minute videos that people
do where you can't really get into
anything substantive
but i i certainly could concentrate on
you know one one idea and that's where
we got the core concept
uh videos from and i i've been using
those
in my classes and it's a lot more it's a
lot more flexible approach
than just saying hey students watch
these three one hour
videos on niches you know this or that
uh instead they can like focus in on
what it is that they they want to study
and as it as it turned out you know
doing things that way
um aligned with youtube's own
weird algorithmic preferences and so
that that got things boosted up and so
you know over time i started producing
other things like
the saddler stories i wanted to do a
little bit more
storytelling about my own life or all
the one-off videos about you know
being here in milwaukee or um
youtube live was a cool thing that they
added in that allowed me to
look at what we're doing right now right
i mean this is this is not something
that we could do 10 years ago
and so i think that's kind of a nice uh
feature that they rolled out and um
you know the channel's just been kind of
steadily growing i think a lot of people
use the videos um some
some some people i think you use it just
for entertainment or to have something
out of the background
other people so let me let me jump into
one of the other things i wanted to talk
about
the comments early on
i got a number of different consistent
kinds of content the
comments that told me that i should keep
doing this this sort of thing
one of them was thank you my professor
won't explain
anything about aristotle or critical
thinking or
pick whatever you want and you know
at first i was like really and then i
thought about some of my peers who are
kind of
kind of jerks in academia and i was like
i guess that that must be the case
and then there were so many of those
comments that i was like oh man this
sucks for students you know
um you know if you're teaching a class
this is a little bit of one of my my
rants and i actually do have a whole
video about this sort of thing
if you're teaching like a class like
intro to philosophy
your goal shouldn't be to like talk
about how wonderful descartes is but
then never explain anything to anybody
when they have
you know quite reasonably all sorts of
questions about
what the hell's going on in descartes
meditations you you're there to explain
it to them
and you know i think
a lot of professors don't don't want to
do that that work and so
my videos were doing that sort of work
it looks like we might have a visitor
coming pretty soon
sassy has gotten off the bed and is
thinking about coming over here come
here girl
oh now she's getting down using her
little ramp
um anyway so that was one kind of of
response and then you know a whole other
kind of response that i got was
i can't afford to go to school i was in
school or i'd like to be in college
and your videos are giving me something
like that experience
of of actually being in a classroom um
so that's really cool and
and i found that very gratifying you
know being able to give people
that sort of thing and then there there
were others who were like
um you know i'm not i'm not getting what
i want
in other venues this is very helpful
practically speaking and so
those are the things that kind of kind
of drove me i mean there's a lot of
people who just say
stuff like thanks and i usually respond
to them saying you're welcome
but the ones that probably um
you know fed into my my doing this stuff
were the ones where
people were saying this is meeting a
need that's not being
satisfied elsewhere and you know it's
not as if i'm like the only
uh video channel that does philosophy
there's hundreds of them out there maybe
thousands
and some of them are way more high
production
and you know they got animations and
music and stuff like that
i always thought it's important yeah i'm
not trying to compete with them right
and they actually get a lot more views
in part because their videos are shorter
and
easier to share but i thought um
you know we need videos explaining
things in a competence
not really
you could say ideological way you know i
mean i don't agree with
nature or content a lot of stuff but i'm
going to present their stuff
as if i do because um somebody
somebody ought to do that in a competent
way and so that's that's essentially
what i've been doing
and it's very gratifying to hit this 100
000 subscribers mark so
you know i think i'm going to actually
look at some of the comments and
um address those and then i'll talk
about
some of the things i want to do with the
the channel
coming up as well um
all right so we talked about the the
rowing
thing and then there's dustin way up
there he has
uh sort of a uh
sad ler thing going on it's always nice
when people get my name right
so many people just say sandler or
statler or things like that
um
dustin asked when is sailor getting his
bronze statue i don't i don't know if
you get a bronze statue
i know there's something you're supposed
to get and i looked at it but
it like the the button right but it
takes a while before they actually get
it
uh here's a good question from uh sunny
what does it mean to you to get this far
in your channel
online work so it is uh
it is kind of a surprise um to to get
this far in but i'm also somebody who
operates in large part
on inertia and i've got forward momentum
going
right oh there's there's a little sassy
i'm gonna pick her up for a second
people can see the 18 year old girl
she's been up here and she's you know
she sometimes wanders in when i'm trying
to shoot a video by the way
in in the studio and uh you know she'll
like
make noises or stuff like that um
yeah she's looking a little reluctant
today isn't she
but she also wanted that attention so
all right let me put her
back down evidently she's you know not
in a super cuddly mood
um yeah it's it's it's it's uh
it's gratifying to to reach that level
um i think it also opens up some other
things for me practically speaking
on youtube but i haven't had the time to
go ahead and explore all that stuff yet
um
let's see dustin says crack your
knuckles again that sounded so nice
um you know it's totally off topic
when when i was a a kid i learned to do
that
and people are like oh don't do that
because then you're going to mess your
joints up and i was like yeah you're
full of crap you know the way i i was
about just about anything doing
having to do with your body you know you
shouldn't smoke because you know that's
going to be hard for your lungs and
i discovered you know when i was in my
my late
20s that that was probably the case um
don't do hard martial arts because
that's hard on your joints
yep you find that out don't listen to
music too loud
either you know when you're like playing
bass in the basement or you know with
your stereo speakers cranked up or going
to concerts or
having you know uh headphones on man now
i'm half deaf
so you know you learn these things the
hard way
my all my joints crack like crazy and
there's a there's a character in
i don't know if any of you have read uh
mervyn pike's gorman gas
trilogy uh in the first one there's this
character who's introduced
um and it is a flayer fray
and all of his joints crack and i
thought it was so funny when when i was
in my 20s you know that that would be
the case
now i'm that guy you know i walk around
and it's creeky crack all
the way all right uh dustin has a
practical question your students have to
grant permission because their voices
would be in the videos was there ever a
conflict with that
so that's an interesting thing yeah the
the ferpa
law requires that you get a release from
students if you're going to use their
their likeness in any way and that would
include their voices but sometimes
you'll actually see students
cross in front of the the camera as well
um i never had a student who's who who'd
struggled with that who wasn't cool with
that
and it's so this is a little bit of a
digression
lecture capture is one of the best
things that you can do
as a professor for a variety of reasons
and actually you want to do the lecture
capture yourself not have the school do
it because usually the school will screw
it up in some way
and then it's their content not your
content
students loved having the capacity to go
back over the class sessions
and review what we talked about or if
they missed a class session
because they were sick or had some
athletic event that they had to go to i
had a lot of student athletes
it was a real godsend to them and it was
it was very helpful um interestingly
there's this this worry that like
recording lectures then uploading them
would lead to
students not showing up to class totally
not the case for my classes
students wanted to be there and they
they typically liked having that
as an available resource for them
the early research on lecture capture
found
that when you look at all the different
things that you can do as an instructor
in order to give students the impression
whether it's true or not
that you actually care about them
lecture capture was one of the
highest ranked things that you could you
could do
now isn't that um bizarre that
and i i thought about this for a long
time what's the reason for that
my only um answers are
basically two well you're giving them a
resource that they can use right that's
helpful for them
and then there's something to do with
like the human form
i think that has that possibility of
connection
you you do have to be able to like be a
speaker who can connect with your
your audience of students in order for
this to work
right you're really dry and dull or
you're condescending
then lecture capture can actually be
counterproductive because students will
be like wow now i actually have on
camera what a jerk that guy
is you know um but if you you know if
you
have an ethos of like caring about
both your subject and your students and
you know you don't like take yourself
too seriously you're willing to joke
around and stuff
it's really powerful um as a means of
education
so ruffy bumble says congrats on
reaching 100k thank you for making
reviewing and lifelong learning free oh
you're very welcome that's that's very
yeah that's it is part of like lifelong
learning
and as i've um you know i've been
teaching now for
since 1999 that's when i had my first
uh not ta-ing for somebody but actually
teaching my own class
so over 20 years and i think over time
i've come to see even in the academic
setting
it's it's really important that we don't
just try to like cram people's heads
full of content but that we we help them
to become
lifelong learners you know i mean if i
teach an ethics class
and the curriculum basically ends
at the end of the semester it's not it's
not much use for people is it
and so that kind of bleeds over into
what i do with the
um youtube videos and i i am you know i
i looked at the podcast stuff just the
other day the saddlers lectures podcast
as i was putting it into a page
where people could you know access all
the playlists easily
there's a lot of stuff there and it just
kind of goes to show you
what you can actually generate if you
just kind of keep your head down
and you're not looking at the big
picture but you're consistently
um churning away at the material and and
i could keep doing this
provided you know youtube stays a stable
platform for the next
i mean i'm not going to live another 50
years most likely i'm 50 now
and i i don't imagine i'm going to hit
100 unless medical technology
drastically improves
and i uh you know lose the weight and
all that sort of stuff
but i could i could live to 80 and i
could see shooting videos for the next
30 years you know um and continuing on
doing this
because there's so much out there to to
do
so yeah
will camp says any advice for an
undergrad looking at
graduate school doctorate programs of
philosophy pitfalls advice for
navigating academia how to effectively
manage
debt my career is hugely inspiring so my
career has
been a lot of um
being lucky in in some respects you know
i didn't have any good advice about
graduate school myself because
where i went to undergrad the professors
were like totally checked out
there were only two of them they were
very old and had no idea how this stuff
worked one of them actually wrote me a
semi-sabotaging
letter of recommendation i was lucky i
had really good test scores
and so things have changed radically
from then the graduate program that i
uh stumbled my way into uh you know
university southern illinois university
at carbondale
um was really quite good at the time
although ranked very low
in in lighters you know philosophical
gourmet [ __ ]
um but it was really a great place
pluralistic department
amazing library compared to so many
other research institutions as i
later found out and you know the
capacity to study the sort of things
that i wanted to study not only with
philosophy but also with classics
english uh speech communication you know
and uh it was a great place for me to to
be
but now they're down four professors and
i don't think they're going to keep
their program so things really do change
a lot over
over time this is a very difficult time
for
um applying for grad school if you
there's like forums that you can
participate in out there and i have
i have some friends and clients who are
you know in the process of
being undergrads applying for grad
school and they're getting turned down
by so many places way more than would
normally be the case
i think partly due to economic crisis
partly due to covid
partly due to other factors as well so
it's it's quite
tough um and i guess the
best bit of advice i would say is don't
take
any of the rejections personally because
um you know
applications for for
graduate school um trying to get a job
publishing those are all black boxes you
you don't really know
what um other people i mean with
publishing you might get a little bit of
you know the reviewer one says this
paper needs this but generally
you you're throwing your your
application fee
and all the documents that they wanted
into a black hole
and they're doing whatever they're doing
in there and it may have zero to do with
you it may have everything to do with
uh factors within the department even
back in in my day
um i applied to to ten places i got
um fellowships at three of the ones that
i got accepted to and i got accepted to
almost every place i applied to but i
also
i didn't you know i only applied to
places that i thought
made sense for me and two of those
places
uh you know two two out of the ten
the whole process got derailed marquette
lost my letters of recommendation
you know which when the chair found out
he was pissed about but it was too late
by that you know
and what did i know you know i'm just a
grad student or an undergrad
actually at that time and uh nobody was
like giving me any useful advice
depaul had a falling out between their
analytic
and continental philosophers in that
year
and the analytics said screw you were
out of here and so depaul sent me a
letter saying
sorry we don't have a graduate program
for the time being we'll we'll think
about it down the line and you know
there's all these weird hiccups and crap
like that um
but the biggest thing is like don't take
this stuff personally it doesn't have
anything to do with with you
as a person and it has everything to do
with the
institution and what they're looking for
um
how to effectively manage debt that's
that's a whole other
thing i mean is it worth taking on
massive debt for
to go study um uh
philosophy at the graduate level it
could be
but it wouldn't be if you're all if your
goal is just to be a professor
you know that's probably no longer a
good trade-off so if you are going to do
the phd
lots of resources out there lots of
discourses about
what else you can do at the phd besides
just trying to be a philosophy professor
cmg has to ever dabble in eastern
philosophy maybe a few core concepts
so i do more than dabble i mean i've
been studying
non-western religions and philosophies
which bleed over into each other since i
was in
high school but i'm handicapped by the
fact that as opposed to like
you know most of the the western
philosophy that i
work on i can i can read things in the
original so if i want to
check on say plato or somebody like that
i can always
um you know go right to the greek um
can't do that with confucius right or uh
contemporary neo-confucianism because i
i although i've dabbled
in in learning uh you know chinese
uh and basically uh you know
characters and then mandarin i never got
very far
and so you know in classical chinese is
a whole different ball game
i'm i think it's better left to other
people who are more expert in it
and actually when i teach classes and
incorporate as i did you know
for this semester confucian tradition uh
taoist tradition i use other people's
videos for that
um sometimes there's they're available
sometimes they're not same thing goes
for indian philosophy i don't read
sanskrit i don't read poly
you know i i don't read any of the other
you know more contemporary languages
so i'm i'm kind of reluctant to
to shoot a lot of stuff because i'm not
i'm not happy with my
own competence when it comes to these
things um
that said i don't know maybe down the
line i will do do some
i mean i definitely need to shoot more
for my own
academic students especially now that
they have me teaching world religions
uh in in a regular sequence as well
um that's a tough class by the way
uh to teach in part total digression
here
um in part because you know in a
semester you're introducing so many like
vast traditions and i you know ways of
thinking about things and you're like
introducing students to terminology
coming from all these different
linguistic backgrounds as well
so all right uh let me
read down a little bit um
atheist says jordan peterson tells his
students not to take notes in class
because he thinks it
deters attention do you tell your
students to not or take notes
i leave it up to them you know there
isn't any like one recipe for how
everybody ought to be
doing things um if you're doing lecture
capture
as as he in fact did that's why he got
to be popular in the first place it
wasn't because of maps of meaning was
such a great book
it's it's it's definitely not um
he put his stuff online and people liked
it if you're doing lecture capture you
could say hey
go back over it and then take notes then
but i mean i don't i don't prescribe for
my students take notes or don't take
notes
that's up to them to figure out you know
um
let's read down a little bit there's a
lot of back and forth about taking notes
here
um
i learned the hard way not to get
involved in the comments section
so this is kind of an interesting point
and some people may disagree with me
on on this but i've always been pruning
the con the the comment section right if
somebody's a jerk
i don't engage with jerks very long so
people who are
you know going to like argue in bad
faith about something or just expound
their own views
i i often give them a few interactions
and then you know i'm like well good
luck with your studies
and if they want to keep going on after
that nowadays i actually offer them that
that piece that i wrote about don't give
jerks time
and then i kick them off you know and
doing so
on twitter with blocking people on
on facebook on my page with doing the
same thing
and on youtube means that the majority
of the interactions that i have
are pretty good and um
you know i look at my my youtube
comments is basically that's my front
porch you know
you're you're commenting on on my video
you're engaging with
me and you get to talk with with me
about stuff
but if you act a jerk i'll kick you off
my front porch just like i would
in in you know physical life and you
know i'm not saying that everybody
should adopt
that as an approach i found that it's
been very good for me
in part because it keeps the trollish
behavior
at a certain level it never lets up
of course but i don't have like tons and
tons of trolls
um i also um you know when when
people were trying to organize oh it's
especially after i did that video
the um response to unwanted advice
you know the the redditors and 4channers
got got all
up in arms about it and it was almost
like
a litmus test putting that out there
because i got all these ideas about like
well who who shouldn't be here
and i put in some key words that
um you know
would uh trigger you know a review of
comments
and it was great it it headed off you
know
people get mobbed on twitter youtube or
stuff like that it headed off that sort
of thing so
yeah comment sections can often be very
toxic
um dustin says
i always watch sandler at 3.7 x playback
speedy sounds so different on normal
speed
wow if you can actually assimilate any
any ideas
at that level uh that's good for you
um that would be very surprising so i'm
guessing that's probably a joke
um oh yeah yeah actually um
milan also says hackers utilize the
comments section i saw a scam the other
day
that um one guy would post that
obviously it's like a bot
account or fake account um i
i broke into my buddies i broke into my
girlfriend's instagram account
using this platform and then somebody
else would say a variety of different
words like
legend or awesome or something like that
yeah there's always like new scams uh
happening it's kind of kind of funny
all right um
here's a good one from jake a fun idea
that could also
potentially continue growing your
channel would be to react to pewdiepie's
videos where he solely talks about
philosophy he has a number of them now
that's actually an interesting idea i've
never done a reaction video
um i imagine it can't be that difficult
to do
in terms of the editing now it's
it's it's funny um
because you know when i heard pewdiepie
was like
putting stuff out there i was like oh
come on you know dude stay in your lane
um but you know maybe uh that might
might actually be kind of
kind of fun to do um so that's that's
uh interesting arvid says thank you for
all these years of non-personal tutoring
professor not only for philosophy my
reading comprehension and english in
german
has gotten a lot better than thanks to a
half hour yeah that's i guess that's one
way to do it
although hegel is not a great writer
right um
as a matter of fact i mean the english
translations are
pretty good right but
you get you're only working with the
material that you've got you know
translating
hegel is not as fun as say translating
schopenhauer nietzsche people who are
much better
stylists um so yeah
but it could work that way you know
sam says i run a page with wow 15
million followers
sun gazing on facebook i wish i could
get your teachings uh
to the facebook humans any ideas
they need it bad i mean why not just
post um
videos from the channel there right i
think that's easy enough
um sun gazing though what's what's that
about
so all right let's let's see what else
we've got here
um
[Applause]
so
yeah jake says reacting to those videos
would be fun
um well here's a good one from
from ethi i try to study philosophy on
my own but i struggle with
procrastination and lack of
motivation to be honest yeah you know um
we're fortunate in that
with the internet before covet and now
even more after cobid
there are lots and lots of philosophical
communities
online and so it could become um
a lot easier to find places to
meet up with other people and like do a
study program
you know if one one good thing one site
i would actually recommend
going to is meetup um there are
like you know local philosophy things
all over the world and most of them went
online
due to the covet pandemic so like our
milwaukee
sophia that's the society of
philosophers in america we get people
coming from all over the place because
we're on zoom now
same thing with the milwaukee stoic
fellowship so that
that's one thing that you could you can
check out i mean
you can still procrastinate obviously
if you're in a reading group but it's a
little bit easier if you're in there
with other people isn't it and you get a
little bit of uh
support provided the other people in the
reading group aren't jerks or something
like that but if they are just go to the
next group you know there's
there's thousands of philosophy groups
out there so i think that that would be
a good thing to do
um oh it just skipped a little bit let's
see
somebody had a question i was just
looking at
um where did it go
all right let's skip up a bit
ah this is really frustrating when i
can't find
the comment i was looking for all right
i'm just going to pick up where i am so
i'm sorry if
people are getting skipped over um
john says i'm a viewer from the middle
east been watching for a while never
subscribed because i felt intimidated
started my philosophy journey recently
and you've been helping a lot congrat
congrats doctor yeah you know um
i suppose you know
i i i would get this every once in a
while people would be like why are you
subscribing to this person why are you
subscribing to this person
and you know i i just hit subscribe when
somebody has something whether i agree
with it or not that i think i might want
to go back to
down the line usually don't because i
don't have the time to watch other
people's videos all that much
um but i suppose if you're in a context
where other people would be like
surveilling that and think that checking
out philosophy could be a bad thing then
you know you kind of have to keep that
under wraps right so
um that makes sense um
let's see here milan asks about thomas
aquinas can i do a series on him i've
done
videos on thomas aquinas i just haven't
done as many
as as other people uh
sam thomas says you can form a super
group with any musicians past a present
who's playing which instrument so for me
of course it'd be metal right
and i would have there's no question
about which um
which person would be the singer it'd be
ronnie james dio who unfortunately
died uh more a little bit over 10 years
ago
and i would go with like a five piece
with an occasional
keyboardist playing as well keyboardist
would be don airy
um the
bassist you know probably steve harris
um although i'd also consider bob
daisley for that
um there'd be a lead guitar and a rhythm
guitar the rhythm guitar would be
would be rude schechner you know because
he is one of the best out there and he's
also a great composer
and it'd be interesting to see what he
and dio did together and then um
lead um that's tough i mean there's so
many
you know incredibly talented guitarists
out there
um but i would probably go with
um that's
that is very tough i mean i might say
fast eddie clark
you know and then on drums i'm you know
i'm not really that into the the
drumming but
um i guess you know there's a lot of
really good people out there maybe cozy
powell
or um
who else would be really solid on that i
mean clive burr
um but you know who knows
what something like that would actually
sound like um
it's kind of an interesting idea i'll
have to i'll put that question to my
friend scott truly
who i do the classic metal class with
and see what he has to say about that
because i think
he probably would have a much better
answer
all right um
let's see what else we got um
dustin says sandler don't discuss how
much longer
you'll live uh you're making me tear up
well you know i i i'm
hoping to live for another 30 years or
so and if i go beyond that that's that's
gravy you know
that's still a long time and it lets me
accomplish
a lot of the things that i want to do um
but you have to be realistic about this
sort of stuff i mean the one good bit of
news is that my
apparently on my biological dad's side
people live a very long time so it
really depends on how many genes i got
from him and
uh you know on the jeans i got from my
mom's somewhat messier gene pool
um and you know how we live and all that
sort of stuff
so all right uh here we go uh the
lifelong learning
thing is huge for me i never felt like i
learned enough philosophy in undergrad
always regretted it now if i do read a
text i have a good commentary that's
yeah that's that's a good way to to put
it and
i actually learned quite a bit myself
going back to these texts
that i'm teaching and commenting on
there's something
about having to
get in front of other people whether
it's in the classroom or
doing a public talk or doing it in terms
of videos
that really makes you like rethink
what you're engaging with and so i think
that's that's a really
uh important point there's mark smith my
my friend and colleague congrats on 100k
a well-deserved milestone now for 200k
we'll see how long that takes uh random
question have you ever thought of making
a wikipedia page
for yourself yes i have thought about it
and it seems like a lot of
work and i might be wrong about that you
know but i
i haven't done the work to actually
research that
so if anybody does want to put together
a wikipedia page
you know about me they should like reach
out and
and and uh i'd be happy to give them
you know the tricky thing is you know
doing the biography
because i think a lot of people don't
know that much about my
my biography and past they know like
bits and pieces of it
and then it would be like you know where
you know where's my work well it's
scattered all over the place right so
a lot of people know me for this thing
over here but don't know me for this
thing over here but i'd be happy to work
with anybody
who actually wants to put together a
wikipedia page
um so that it wouldn't you know be
reflective of what i what i actually do
um that would be kind of cool but
you know um it's not something i want to
do the work for myself
i'm kind of lazy that way um
let's see here
so here's a good point from uh milahan
you don't need to go into debt in order
to get a superior education and
philosophy books are
cheap are cheap and scholars are online
and there's two sides to that i would
say
one side is that yeah you can do a lot
of the stuff on your own
um it's not quite the same thing as like
being in a grad school
program that said and here's the other
side of it there's a lot of grad school
programs that people pay lots of money
for
and they're not getting what they
thought they were going to
get by paying all that money for it so
you know i'll use some examples right so
marquette university and i'm pointing
that way because it's it's
12 blocks from here to to the west and
that's a place where i've taught and had
an office and you know
interacted with the grad students and i
presented there
and have a lot of friends and colleagues
there they have a pretty
you know good grad student culture there
that said you know even if you get an
assistantship they don't give you full
tuition
remission and marquette costs you know
uh
high 40s low 50s uh thousands per per
year to go to
and you know they're not placing
graduates like they used to back in the
1990s and early 2000s
when they had a very high job placement
rate
and you know so it's it's not
necessarily
a good trade-off for the money that you
have to do
and you know if you go to other places
like i know
i have friends who work at st john's
university in queens
and they don't know each other and
they're professors and i was like how do
you not know each other and they're like
well we only come in for
these meetings every once in a while and
to teach our classes and then we get the
hell out of there you know and i was
like don't you have like
office hours and like walk down the
halls and meet each other
and they're like nah we don't do that we
just get out of here right away and i
was like well if the professors aren't
actually engaging with each other
i doubt there's much of a grad grad
student you know interaction which is
important for for learning
you know having peers that you work with
and you know they probably charge as
much as marquette does so i think that
that's
you know another issue as well
um
call almost any thoughts on an essay
connecting early reading books like the
mouse and the motorcycle
in the development of moral decision
making and the virtues not not for me
but i think that's that's a really
viable
area of study there are there are people
who specialize in philosophy for
children
and i think that's you know that's the
way
to smuggle in philosophy in the k
through 12
education stuff i i think we really do
need a lot more
philosophy getting introduced in
american education
that might be a really great way to do
it you know
writing some stuff about that and then
like doing videos about that and then
um getting educators interested in that
all right um
let's see who else we got uh
lot of various thanks stuff you're
welcome to everybody
um some stuff about islamic philosophy
same same deal with that you know i
don't read arabic or
any of the other useful uh tools for
for that um although you know it's
really one of the good things about
marquette they have the aquinas and the
arabs project
where graduate students are actually
researching this stuff
um
let's see
there's a lot of stuff here about
islam and philosophy um
let's see here um
brandon asks about two different shows
that i don't actually watch curious if
you've seen lost or have any thoughts
among the characters are john locke
david hume or so or if not the good
place
so i watched like the first three
episodes of the good place and then i
was like
this ain't for me i guess it got better
but you know
it was kind of a turn off and this is
you know a similar thing with
mathematics
writers typically when they're trying to
do
philosophy they do it badly and
and they they stick with the stuff that
they remember from undergrad like the
trolley problem
or things like that and it's just not
it's not interesting enough
for somebody who does it you know it'd
be sort of like watching a thing about
heavy metal and all they do is talk
about metallica's black album and you're
like
well okay there's there's more to it
than that
um never watched lost i guess they had
characters
named after famous philosophers but i
don't i don't really know much about
that
um
let's see salaam says
thankfully i could be part of your
channel just before it hit 100k
channel's a gem and you're one of the
most consistent channels
i've seen and the consistency is
something that is often
underrated um
and uh apparently youtube
likes consistency in terms of
recommendations you know
uh so that that's that's quite good um
let's scroll down a bit more let's see
um
there's a lot of back and forth about uh
islamic philosophy here
here's one from ashen what are the
elements of stoicism you don't accept
i'm reading through a new stoicism right
now well that's that's
that's a achievement right there
actually i have it right here because i
was talking about the client
we're talking about becker's a new
stoicism which is one of those books
that a lot of people buy and very few
people actually make it through because
it's a tough
tough work i i've actually worked
through the entire
book except for the appendices um
with with a client and it took us four
months of
weekly meetings to do that so you've got
your work cut out for you there
but it's a really great book and it was
very important in the stoic revival
i mean i don't i don't um
what what don't i accept i mean i don't
accept the stoic cosmology
um although it's it's interesting
when you look at it you know it's not
all
consistent you know even like whether
whether souls survive after death seneca
has a few things now these are in
letters on consolation
where he's like trying to provide some
some consolation where a few good people
get to go up by the stars and stuff like
that
um i don't really accept much of the
stoic
argument about determinism and their
form of compatibilism
um when it comes to anger i'm sort of
more
sort of a mix of aristotelian and stoic
perspectives i think stoics has some
really useful things to say about it but
i don't buy their zero tolerance
policy when it comes to it um
i mean that said there's a lot of stoic
philosophy
and somebody does work on medieval
philosophy and particularly pre
you know like let's incorporate
aristotle like you know thomas aquinas
stuff
the the stuff from like the 11th century
backwards
there's a lot of stoic stuff in there
because
a lot of neoplatonism incorporated stoic
stuff
as sort of like the bottom level it
wasn't just aristotelianism it was also
with platonism on top it was stoic stuff
the
ideas about uh how the emotions work and
the
vices that also made its way through
vagra's ponticus
into uh john cassian's treatment of the
capital vices
and so there's there's a lot of stoic
stuff that makes its way through
um into like
early medieval thought and i i find that
stuff pretty interesting as well
so gutter growing says i'd run your
wikipedia page i don't even know if
that's how it works do people run pages
see that's that's a oh here's a great
one from dammit albert
how much of your wikipedia article is
just favorite metal bands
i think that actually should make its
way in there because one of my
side projects as some of you may know
besides the classic metal class that
scott truly and i do
once a month every every uh third
saturday of the month
this this month by the way we're doing
german metal bands from the 1970s to the
mid-80s
um i also have a blog called heavy metal
philosopher
and so that that would probably have to
make it in there
milhan says can i do any symbolic logic
videos you know i've thought about doing
that
i would need to get my hands on some
like contemporary
textbooks it's been a while since i
taught logic and i know they changed the
textbooks from time to time
but i can always just like you know
request them and pretend i'm going to
teach a class on them
and have places send them to me um
it is something i could do i'd have to
free up more time um
and i you know i do plan this coming
fall to be doing less
academic teaching and more other things
including developing online courses in
my study with sadler academy
but um it's tough to get in
even the stuff that i i get done right
now
um all right let's let's scroll down and
see a little bit
more um
a lot of uh
well that okay that's interesting mia
lehon says so many philosophy
majors only study christian philosophers
and never expand their skills i think
masters should expand to islam which is
a new area to explore
very very few christian philosophers are
actually being studied in most academic
philosophy departments i mean and if
they are it's not usually
christian philosophers you know
descartes kind of pitches his his
project as christian philosophy and
there is a god in there but it's not the
god of christianity it's a
deistic god quite frankly um
so i would i would say that there are a
few places that
do that most of them will say like well
aquinas is our main
our main topic but they're really far in
the minority
but i'm i'm all for like you know
widening the canon and including a lot
more people the
the trick is you actually have to be
competent in teaching them you know
so that's that's the issue um
a lot of the time mark asks something
that i don't know if i'll ever do what
are you going to record a sick bass lick
to use for video intros or even shred
some banjo
now the banjo i play more often
i need to start practicing again
i also need to like fix the action on it
and there i got to get my friend scott
to walk me through
how to do that and i don't even have the
right allen wrench it turns out for
for fixing it when my daughter had she
put the action real low
and i don't know why she did that
because i get a lot of frat buzz but
i might be able to pick it up in the
summer but i'm
so you know compared to where i was as
an undergraduate when i was playing bass
every day i'm so far away
from that i i am thinking though about
having scott
record um one of the things i'd like to
do
is is actually do more stuff about metal
and i might actually do that in
different channel
because i have heavy metal philosopher
reserved
if i ever find the time and i was
thinking i would get him
uh to to record some like
intro tracks and outro tracks and stuff
like that that would be kind of cool
um but you know a lot of what i've
had to learn to do is to get other
people who are better at stuff
and can do a better job to um
help me out with it you know um
so all right let's see what else we got
in here um
scene says my philosophy teacher assigns
your videos that's nice i'm glad that
that
people uh do that because it can be
quite helpful for their students and
why reinvent the wheel like i said when
i'm when i'm teaching
uh stuff about um chinese philosophy i
i use other people's videos because
they're they're more competent than
talking about it
with me so all right um
it looks like it skipped a little bit um
cmg says how many hours a day of
philosophy study and reflection would
you recommend per day
10 to 18 hours that's not really
manageable for most of us
i try to do some reading in the morning
and
you know i'm mostly reading i'm doing at
any given point is
to get ready for what i'm teaching or
shooting videos on
um so you know
if you if you actually have the capacity
to
engage in reflection for 10 hours a day
that's a full-time job
and that would be kind of nice but
that's not that's not available
to most of us um
arvid asks about what do i think of
saxon's new album of covers
i listened to a few of them i mean it's
definitely saxon doing it raven did
something similar a few years back when
they did had their kickstarter project
for
uh extermination they had uh
what was it called party favors or
something and i i like listening to
covers
by of of stuff especially
where it's like a cool metal cover of
something that wasn't originally
metal you know there's a long history of
that
um a great example is you know like
judas priest green man elishi with the
two prong crown if you ever listened to
the fleetwood mac
that's way different or even you know
judas priests diamonds and rust which
has become
also one of their their main standards
they play almost every concert
um sometimes you can have stuff that's
already heavy but is being done better i
i actually like wasps covers of the real
me
and uh locomotive breath quite a lot i
think they're
they're quite good um
gutter groans says uh he has to get run
by someone who dr
stops people from editing it to say
duran duran is your favorite
i actually liked her andrean quite a lot
um they're
they're a band that i started listening
to
when i was a kid because they were on
the radio and
i sort of like rediscovered them in the
mid 90s in part because i saw the video
on mtv
as i was working late night security for
come on come undone
and i was like oh that's that's it's
pretty good i'll go out and get that
tape
um that was the day that i bought that
tape stone temple pilot's core
and one other tape and i don't remember
uh offhand what it was
and i remember listening to them at you
know i had to put it
i put them in the boom box at my uh at
that time
girlfriend's place um where
i was like you know hanging out and
listening to him there
um so you know duran duran you know not
bad
um i actually play some some of their
songs you know
um let's see what else we got here
um
somebody asked do i ever reference alan
watts interpretations in my lectures on
chinese philosophy i don't have any
lectures on chinese philosophy so
it's kind of a moot point but i probably
wouldn't be
mentioning watt because i think watt was
a great guy for his time
i'm not into his his sort of shtick um
and he reminds me of too many hippies
that i've known in in my time
that uh would spout the same sort of
stuff so i'm not really that big on
that approach but then again you know i
haven't looked at him for at least 10
years so maybe i'd
i'd enjoy them um
let's see philosophy students who don't
this is
milhan who don't study theology are weak
in skill
uh it's not necessarily so um depends on
what theology they're studying
you know
all right mark says history of metal
covers of non-metal songs might be an
interesting topic
for the classic metal class i was just
thinking that
that could actually be a great topic you
know how do you take
things that are not even necessarily
metal adjacent
we talk about like certain hard rock
stuff being
not metal but at least being the same
kind of stuff that would be in like you
know
uh your dirtbag cousin's uh
tape deck or something like that as
you're listening to it
um like if you're gonna do redo fog hat
or
you know jethro tall or uh stuff like
that but then
what about stuff that's really out there
that you take and you
you make a nice cover of it so
let's see here um
sam do you agree with nietzsche that
scientists are just theologians and lab
coats the more i study science
philosophy and theology the more i'm
starting to fall in line with nietzsche
on this so the idea there is
articulated in the genealogy that you
know
first you've got the priests and
theologians and you have the
philosophers
then you have the scientists this sounds
very much like august comp doesn't it
right
uh theological metaphysical positive
science
it's not it's not an idea unique to
nietzsche i think that a lot of people
who are convinced of like you know
science and logic and facts and stuff
like that
are really basically they have a
theology that's
by a different name um and
you know they are continuing something
that they're they're
you know claiming to react against but
they have a lot of the same tendency
sure i'd say he's right about that
does that apply to all scientists
definitely not you know
uh ecology says congratulations i'm
grateful to allah for guiding me to you
and i'm grateful to you for the
knowledge you share that's very nice
yeah
um a lot of a lot of our life is kind of
uh
serendipitous here's kind of a silly
question
from truth and knowledge doctor are you
aware that islamic scholars and
philosophers translated many greek works
and facilitate its arrival to the
western world
why wouldn't i be i mean that's basic
knowledge that we got when we were in
like world civ
you know back in undergrad and in high
school so
that's uh not anything new to me
um as a matter of fact i
will say that the idea that like
aristotle was unknown to the west until
you know
the great translation project that's
that's actually kind of [ __ ] because
the monks were you know copying cicero
and
seneca and actually if you read seneca's
letters and you read cicero you'll get a
lot of
aristotle right through that boethius
had translated some of the work same
thing with plato and all that but
it is true that the translation project
was which was
by the way a joint project of muslims
christians jews you know
was was quite important then there were
also a lot of texts that were recovered
uh after um the byzantine empire was
falling and scholars
fled uh bringing greek texts with them
from that area
so we have a much more complicated
picture to that right
um
[Music]
all right let's see what else we can
take up
uh keeps jumping because so many people
are writing things
um ashton asks a good question i'm
interested in learning german to be able
to read 18th 19th century philosophers
in the original
is the german from that era
significantly different than the modern
yeah i mean it's if you're reading a
german newspaper today it's
certainly going to be different than
reading you know nietzsche
certainly different than reading like if
you're on 18th century lichtenberg
or going in further back reading some
alive and it's his early essays
late essays rather he wrote his last
three in german to try to make that into
a philosophical language
just like when you're reading hume you
know his english
can be quite difficult for english
readers today right or
if you think about french um
d derose french is not the same thing as
you would get in a contemporary issue of
lear you know
that's kind of a common place so
ray i asked will you ever upload a sad
saddled saddlerized by the saddler video
on your saddler stories
playlist oh talking about like how i
used to
be kind of vicious in argument that's
not a bad idea i should probably
probably do that uh that's a good idea
um let's see
ryan says congratulations dr sailor i've
been watching your videos for about six
years
what do you think the difference is
between being a philosophy professor and
a philosopher
so some philosophy professors are indeed
philosophers
in and there's there's no like recipe or
definition of
the philosopher any more than there is a
philosophy but you can talk about living
a philosophical life
i think if like you you know
you you have your thing that you do as
your academic specialty and it doesn't
have any impact on your existence
um you're not very philosophical then
um although with some things it would be
hard to see how it would you know
but there's a lot of people who live
very compartmentalized
lives right so that's that's kind of a
a problem um johan any thoughts on
scrutiny's
short history of philosophy haven't read
it can't imagine it's going to be
particularly good most his
most histories of philosophy aren't
particularly good they're from some sort
of take you know and they're very
uh you know skewed in one way or another
um you probably should read a variety of
histories of philosophy you know uh
college i'd like to know what you
believe the essence or the true nature
of philosophy
is to you i just said i i don't think
there is a
single essence to philosophy there's a
lot of different things
in in philosophy's history that we've
called philosophy
i'm cool with there being a legitimate
pluralism to it
you know um so yeah
um let's see here
oh x blue bells how is your class going
teaching the good life through
philosophy so i'm not actually teaching
the good life through philosophy
i'm teaching a class called philosophy
mindfulness in life
which is focused in particular on uh
philosophies as ways of life which
of course includes the good life and
happiness but also focuses really
heavily on
philosophical practices or as adult
likes to call them spiritual exercises
so it's going okay um as usual
things never go quite how you expect
them to
or as well as you want them to students
need a good bit especially in this
covid19 time
need a good bit of like you know
bringing them back into the fold when
they wander off
um the students seem to enjoy it quite a
bit
and it's you know so a little bit of
background
one of the main places i teach doesn't
have a philosophy program
and it's actually none of the places i'm
teaching right now actually do have a
philosophy program
milwaukee area technical college they
only have two philosophy classes because
they're a technical college
intro and ethics philosophy is under
social science there
carthage college did have a philosophy
program until
they phased out 15 of their major
programs this
this last summer with like about two
weeks notice to the people involved in
them and then fired all those professors
which is a real jerk move and now i'm
under
just liberal arts there but the main
place i was talking about milwaukee
institute of art and design
the place that i really enjoy teaching
the most they're all
it's an art school you know art and
design school
and it's one of the best in the nation
um and
it's uh you know i got brought in to
like add more humanities electives in
the philosophy area
the students really really like taking
philosophy classes
and i'm really happy to be able to bring
that sort of stuff
to them as well so and i'll mention too
that my wife
teaches for them as well also as an
adjunct and brings in not only you know
things having to do with philosophy but
also food studies and they
love that stuff as well too so it's
really quite cool
so the class is going pretty good i'd
say you know um
all right julian says is there a tension
between teaching philosophy generally
and forming your own philosophical views
what are some philosophical topics you
have your own settled opinions on
i don't think it has to be attention i
mean
i guess if you're the sort of person who
thinks that like you're either doing
original stuff or you're like
you know following in other people's
footsteps but i think there's there's a
wide range in between i don't think you
can do
in these days i don't think you can do
any effective original stuff
without knowing a good bit of what's
already been done and then like figuring
out where you want to position yourself
in there i think that's by the way one
of the big flaws with wittgenstein um he
should if he'd read a lot more he would
have been a way
better philosopher and people are coming
to understand
now even within the analytics sphere
that he's been way way overrated
um in part because of the poverty of
their their own you know
uh stuff at the time um
i don't see a a real tension there
unless somebody places it there
so you know
all right we're gonna have to start
wrapping up pretty soon because uh
um i gotta do some work on
on some writing um
edmond asked love your self-directed
series i was wondering who you might
have lined up for the next one yeah
i want to get back to doing those in the
summer so
definitely want to do medievals like
augustine
i did anselm and i did early christian
stuff but augustine
boethius thomas aquinas
um and who else do i wanna who else
would be really important to hit on
um i mean those are probably i mean
maybe abelard as well um
early modern there's a lot of thinkers
that i think could be quite useful to do
those on descartes would be like a
you know automatic hume would be another
one
um thomas hobbes it could be good to do
one on spinoza because so many people
love the ethics but don't understand it
you know
sort of like you know i was talking
about a new stoicism people buy the book
and they they
rave about it but they don't actually
like work through it and assimilate it
so there's that and then you know later
moderns like hegel or nietzsche
molestonecraft you know the same people
that i do a lot of talking on
i would like to do some other stuff in
ancient philosophy as well like you know
plutarch for example is somebody who i
think
really underrated great middle
platonist that's well worth reading
alexander of aphrodisias is another like
aristotelian
you know the commentator he was called
by the medievals
um well worth checking out so you know
all right um let's see here
sam says where are the 20 20 versions of
nietzsche plato kierkegaard schopenhauer
they're out there you just got to look
for them you know
i mean schopenhauer wasn't very well
known in his time was he
neither was kierkegaard actually even
nietzsche was
mark says to know if you're aware of the
lost media fad online
i was curious that there were any videos
you recorded and never uploaded or got
taken down for whatever reason
i did get a video taken down once and it
was
my daughter my oldest daughter engaging
in it was at the family reunion
our family reunions are pretty big
events they've been going on since
1975. uh a big reunion is
200 people a small reunion is 70 and
it's often in between
and it goes on for two and a half days
and we have a talent show on
on the second night going way back to
when it used to be cited at a different
place
um and so my you know my
eldest daughter was doing some ballet
stuff
but she'd done it to
i don't know what what song it was but
anyway i used the song
and within like seconds of uploading it
youtube
smacked it down it was it was removed
but that's the only time i've had a
video
removed um i don't think i have an awful
lot of stuff that
got uploaded and didn't get uh
released other than a bunch of videos
actually i do have a bunch of videos
but i'm probably going to take them out
of the main channel and send them over
to my my ad milwaukee institute of art
and design channel because i did some
videos on
marjon satrapi's graphic novel
persepolis just to like give the
students some background stuff
you know um that would help them out
understanding it
it's funny because satrapy and i are
like the same age
you know and one one of the videos is
actually about what's going on with her
references to iron maiden
uh because she she had like iron maiden
posters and stuff like that
so it was a lot of fun explaining it but
i don't think i have too much other
stuff floating around you know most of
what i've got
has been put out there uh ecology says
thank you for answering my question
congratulations i pray for your success
is there a way i can become your pupil
or student whether in person or not
well obviously in covid times there's no
in person anything right
um we we are very careful about that i'm
not even teaching my
academic classes in person um
i do you know i do it depends on what
you mean by being a student
you know i offer tutorial services which
are one-on-one where i work with people
i have a lot of clients i've been doing
that since the like mid
20 teens
i also do online classes in my own study
with sadler academy
i haven't done an awful lot with that
lately because i've been so busy with
academic work but that that's another
possibility and you know i'll probably
be offering
more seminars in the future but i do a
lot of online events
you know every every month um this month
we're going to be trying something out
with the
ribbon platform i'm going to be talking
about marcus aurelius and
how to you know approach him as a
beginner
so there's lots of different uh avenues
i would say that
you know the way to find out about these
things is
every video that i've got it says like
you know for
philosophy tutorials here's the link or
you know there's my facebook author page
there's reason i owe my business page
that offers
different things and then there's the
study with sadler academy
so these are all ways that people can do
it i'm
probably you know going to be teaching
less academic classes
myself because i want to concentrate
more on writing projects
coming up in the fall
um dr bevis are you familiar with
pirado's work
um i actually released five videos on it
later earlier this uh this year so yes
um
let's see
truth and knowledge how important is the
philosophy of science for us to
understand science i think it's a
neglected field yeah probably it's not
an area of my own specialization but i
think people can can um you know
certainly get into that
um oh here's a great one from dawood
what do i foresee for the future of
academic philosophy i know some
departments are looking to diversify
the syllabi and incorporate more
non-western works what does this mean
for phd graduates
i mean practically speaking nothing most
departments right now
are kind of in a holding pattern trying
to
stay alive except for the ones that are
really well funded you know
that have lots of prestige and money um
i mean when you look at a lot of
philosophy departments it's already
pretty
diverse um and you're never going to
have like a
totally inclusive curriculum so i think
you know
there's there's a lot of possibilities
for studying
all sorts of interesting stuff but you
also when you go into a philosophy
department
you don't have to stick just with what
they want you to read
i was saying this yesterday in response
to a question in the ema
you know i like to say it's a free
country meaning that
hey it's your time it's your brain it's
your
studies if so for example if the
philosophy department is like alexis de
tocqueville sucks
nobody should read them you can be like
well i won't tell them that i'm reading
him but i'm going to read his stuff you
know and what are they going to do to
you like kick you out
um unless they have something kind of
like an inquisition going on it's not
like they can do an awful lot about you
reading stuff that you're
not supposed to read we had all sorts of
reading groups
outside of the formal curriculum when i
was in grad school
very often with students who are not
even in the philosophy department but in
speech communications or english or
history or
stuff like that so you know all right um
let's see
ashton has a a question about something
i talked about before
but it's good to reiterate it i'm
graduating college next month and bummed
about leaving philosophy
discussion behind is it possible for
people not in the milwaukee area to join
your sophia chapter discussions online
not only possible it's actual it happens
all the time
and not only are sophia chapter but all
the ones all over the united states
as a matter of fact we're not really
that active
compared to some of the bigger more
established ones and i i would get like
on meet up or
go to you know the sofia website and
find the ones that are doing cool stuff
and
you know if they want to be jerks and be
like oh you're not from lexington or
something like that then just
you know pick yourself up and go to the
next one there's so many
cool um philosophy meetups and clubs and
stuff like that out there
that you could easily fill up your
calendar with with going to
to them you know um
let's see all right um
well let me let me actually bring this
to a close a little bit i think we've
kind of run through a lot of comments
by talking about what what i'm going to
do in the channel so obviously
core concepts going to keep churning
those out i need more for my classes i'm
trying to fill in gaps
here and there the half part hegel were
you know
probably going to finish it up this year
which is cool and then i'll start
thinking about what other
big books i'd want to do i've already
done
by the way and i'm going to remaster
these i've done the half hour hegel
approach
with epictetus's and coridian half an
hour
you know commentary at a time they're in
a different channel
um and i'm gonna take those remaster
them to fix some of the
sound as best as i can and then um
re-upload them in my main channel but
i'm going to do descartes
meditations i don't know if i have the
the really great
version yeah there it is this is one of
my favorite
finds um this is a version that
has the french translation
and descartes latin and so i'm going to
do
you know with the carts latin french
translation
english translation probably adam and
tannery you know
um and um it also includes the uh
responses and objections and so i'll
probably do that work
and then i'll think about you know what
do i want to do next um
people like the sandler stories i'm
going to keep up with those
um the caption contest seem to be quite
popular
so i'll probably do more of those um
and what else you know i had that
saddler soapbox
series that i started and i i'm thinking
about re-redoing that
those are just basically rants that i do
and people can weigh
in on that um what are other series that
that actually let me let me put this as
a question what are other
things that i've done that people want
to see more
of um i mean and the reason i may have
done it
not done a lot of it could be like i
just haven't had the time
lately um so some people say they like
the
the the the rants that's nice
um now here's a question interesting
well i wait for people to say what
they'd like to see
in there um does anyone have a mega
playlist of every
sadler vid made on youtube so youtube
lets you make playlists that can be
quite long
but playlists become incredibly
cumbersome
once they get past 200 videos um
so you know i i like the core concept
playlist you notice
i broke it up into sections because it's
too hard on the back end to manage stuff
you know once things get beyond about
200 videos
so uh milahan says start debates
not interested in debates there's plenty
of people to do that debates are rarely
productive
a podcast there's already a podcast
called sadler's lectures
you know it's easy enough to find um
it's available on pretty much every
podcast thing
toby says i'd like to see you engage
with the weird fiction side of sci-fi
i already did china melville in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
um oh here's a good one dad would your
clubhouse discussion on stoicism was
great love to see you more on clubhouse
i will be going more on clubhouse and
doing so
with my wife andy shaka um
both of us are on clubhouse and we're
going to start doing that in may so
that's that's a good one
um let's see here
people are saying we want a video about
islamic philosophy i already said told
you that i'm probably not going to do
that
um and uh you know um
people can can why why don't this is the
sort of thing where you want to find
other people who are doing it i don't
have to do everything right
i i try to stick to what i'm good at um
spinoza will probably do as well um
yeah only fans account that won't be
happening anytime
soon um i don't i don't know that
anybody would actually want that
um podcast with fans
okay that's kind of an interesting idea
you know once i reach a sufficient level
of patreon support i will
do more with the podcast i think
more dr sadler's philosophical
developments okay i haven't done any of
those for a while
mark asks have you considered doing
interviews where you interview
i used to do yeah they're called the
ideas that matter there's a whole
playlist of that where i'd sit down with
people
and i've realized you know since covet
has happened
we're we're gonna have to go to like
doing zoom interviews and i'm gonna do
i'm gonna just start doing those
probably this summer with some of my
friends and colleagues and then i'll
expand it out so
yeah um
interviews with fans i'm not sure how
that would actually happen
but that's an interesting idea i'll have
to kick that around
people are saying livenet spinoza yeah
those are things i
i certainly could do now panels with
fans i don't know how that happens
either
um certainly on youtube is kind of tough
to do
um oh truth of knowledge the orientalist
news coming out
well it's nice of you to channel saeed
uh very sad a philosopher will not talk
about islamic philosophers very biased
sucks for you i guess then you know um
so you might want to reconsider whether
you want to try to
spar with me about that on here in a
celebration video but
that's life uh milahan says have
call-ins with fans
yeah again i have to think about how
that would actually
happen um that's that's not a bad idea
though
um that would be kind of interesting
all right so i'm gonna put out some
polls in the coming like week or so
about some of these things like the um
sadler's soapbox and
uh things like that to try to get
people's feedback
and so that could be um quite
interesting
and uh
yeah um
i think that's probably a good place to
close things off so
i'm i meant for this to go for about an
hour it went for an hour and a half
i have to get cracking on some work on
this and some paper that i haven't uh
been been doing so
uh the conference by the way i'll put in
a pitch for this so
if you're interested in anselm of
canterbury
saint anselm's college is having the
seventh uh
saint anselm conference the first one
started in 2000 they've been having them
every
two or three years since then there's a
lot of great papers
it's all online you can register for it
for 10 bucks and it lasts two days
i'm going to be giving a paper uh my
my good friend and colleague harold
covley is going to be giving a paper
there's quite a few other people like
big names burn google
thomas williams maria coalish will be
giving
papers that i'm really looking forward
to so that could be
um it could be of interest to people
i will be actually recording my
talk that i give for that although i
might just record it
separately from the zoom session because
i can't be guaranteed we're gonna get a
really good
um zoom thing and
uh yeah let's uh go from there thanks to
everybody who
who came and joined in the celebration
um
and i'll see we've got more you know
online events coming up
this month and hopefully i'll see some
of you at those
have a great evening for those of you
in the time zones much further east
some of you might might be the middle of
the morning
and a good afternoon for everybody else